the Joe Rogan experience yeah no it's a
it's an amazing time amazing time for
this part and I mean it's amazing time
it's just amazing time for martial arts
period I mean I think martial arts right
now is that the highest level that it's
ever been in the history of people
fighting each other you know it's a
sighting moment as well because now you
got so many different hopefuls no we got
six or seven people that they just need
one morning not only just know one more
this person just need one more then they
jump off and it you know it becomes
super strong because we we need more
stars right now we got Conor but when
it's kind of gonna come back I think
Ronda might do to WWE thing John she's
done I'm pretty sure I think the WZ
thing is a good look I know she was at
it like dinner with Triple H and our
Asian
Slater so I hope she does that man cuz
people said whatever they want but Ronda
Rousey was she was that girl at one
point she was and she put us all on the
map in a different way and had the old
lady did the 75 year old lady at the
airport talking about MMA so you know
she she's a GG paid our do and I think
if she want to gracefully walk into a
different realm WWE film I think she
just produced some type of series that
uh you know we should support her on
that I agree I agree 100%
and I really don't want to see her fight
again I would she wants to fight again
but what if I would I would want to see
is her move to a camp that could address
the entire game of MMA in a much more
comprehensive way and not tell her that
she's great at something if she's really
I would want her to go to like Matt Hume
or someone like that but who who is she
actually fight she's not too big of a
name she's right fight someone who's
coming up fight someone get a tuneup
fight get an actual for me but I don't
think she wants to fight I mean I think
at a certain point in time you have
enough money in the bank you have enough
notoriety and fame and she's got a lot
of aspirations outside the sport she's
married now who knows she might want to
start a family you right you're right
listen I wanna see is George st. Pierre
first
time with a July July I say that's my
big prediction with UNC make it happen
the prediction big prediction for me is
that I just hear my first fight back
charge my shoulder sore I can't hurt so
I can't even pawn how do you sleep I
can't punch out hard to sleep I mean
George this is if you want to fight me
brother this is the time at the time
George give me your right now wake that
money George
[Applause]